hi everyone this is Professor M de
science and today I want to discuss
compatible observables this is another
one of our videos on rigorous quantum
mechanics the first question you
probably have is what are compatible
observables
they are simply observables that commute
the second question is why are
compatible observables important the
physical properties associated with
compatible observables can be measured
simultaneously in quantum mechanics I
contrast if two observables don't
commute for example the position and
momentum then it is impossible to
measure the associative properties
simultaneously in quantum mechanics and
that leads to some of the strangest
features of this theory in this video
we're going to prove the basic
mathematical result that underpins all
of these ideas which is that two
compatible observables share a common
set of eigenstates so let's go the
starting point today is this equation
here showing two hermitian operators a
and B that commute the key result of the
video is that if a and B commute then it
is always possible to find the common
set of eigenstates of a and B that form
a basis in state space I cannot
emphasize enough how important this
result is in quantum mechanics it
implies that these two observables can
be measured simultaneously as I
discussing the videos on measurements
what I want to do in the rest of the
video is to prove it the proof relies on
both the matrix formulation of quantum
mechanics and the properties of
hermitian operators so make sure you
have seen those videos before moving on
what I want to do in this first slide is
to give you a sketch of the proof and
the rest of the video provides the
details let's imagine we have calculated
the eigenvalues an eigenstate of a we
can write the operator a in matrix form
in the basis of its own item States and
in this basis the matrix is diagonal and
the diagonal entries are given by the
eigenvalues of the operator which I call
lambda I imagine that I have some
degenerate eigen values so I have G 1
lambda 1 entries G 2 lambda 2 entries
and so on the eigenstates of a that
share give an eigen value are not
uniquely defined we can make linear
combinations amongst them to find new
set of equally valid eigenstates the
matrix a will look diagonal in any of
these possible bases
to be if the eigenstate of a that we
have chosen as a basis were also
eigenstate of B then we would also look
diagonal what we will see in this video
is that an arbitrary choice for the
eigenstate of a will in general not lead
to a state of B in this case B looks
almost diagonal but not quite there is a
block here of sites g1 by v1 with
nonzero entries arising from the
eigenstate associated with lambda 1 then
a second block of size G 2 by G 2 and so
on the entries are 0 outside these
blocks but not within them a matrix of
this form that is almost but not quite
agonal is called a block diagonal matrix
in this video we'll see that we can play
with the flexibility we have here to
make linear combinations of eigenstate
of a and we will always be able to find
at least one linear combination for
which the resulting states are also
eigenstate of B with this special choice
of basis then the matrix B will also be
diagonal when we have done that then we
can make the statement here so we all
remember one thing from this video it
should be this result operators that
debate this result are called compatible
observables in quantum mechanics and as
explained in the videos on measurements
compatible observables can be measured
simultaneously to prove the intuitive
result we just discussed let's start
with the eigenvalue equation for a which
is a PSI equals lambda beside the first
thing we want to prove is that a new cat
chi which is obtained by acting with be
on side it's also an eigenstate of a
with the same eigenvalue lambda to do
this we act with a on Chi we then use
the definition of kite write it out
explicitly in terms of B and soil as AM
B commute that we can exchange them to
obtain this using the fact that sy is an
eigenstate of a we can write this where
we have moved the scalar lambda at the
beginning and finally we obtain lambda
chi as I claimed AE acting on Chi gives
lambda kind so Chi is also an eigenstate
of a with the same eigen value lambda so
what does this imply first let's imagine
that lambda is known degenerate you'll
remember that this means that lambda has
a single eigenstate associated with it
although these eigenstate is only
defined up to a multiplicative constant
we have just found
both sigh and beeps I are eigen state of
lambda with the same eigenvalue
this means that beeps I and side must be
the same eigen state up to a constant
and I will call the proportionality
constant mu but what is this equation
now it is just an eigenvalue equation
for P which tells us that side is also
an eigenstate of B with eigenvalue mu so
what does all of this mean if a and B
commute and their eigenvalues spectra
are known degenerate then the eigenstate
of a and B are the same this is it we
have proved the statement made at the
beginning of the video when we have
known the general spectra when we have
the general eigen values The Situation's
be more complicated to understand what
happens in this case we first need to
lay out the notation that we will use
let's consider the eigenvalue equation
of the hermitian operator a as written
down here i've written its most general
form in which lambda n are the eigen
values and different eigen values are
labeled by the index n sy n i is an
eigen state which I have here labeled
with two indices the index n is telling
us that the eigen state is associated
with the eigenvalue lambda n and the
index I is telling us that there may be
more than one item state with the same
eigen value lambda n I run from 1 to GN
and it tells us that there are GN eigen
states that share the same eigen value
what do we know about the eigen state of
a hermitian operator in the video on
hermitian operators we learned that for
an N dimensional state space there are n
linearly independent eigen States
this means that capital n must be equal
to the sum over the GN values to see
this explicitly we can write out all I
can state in order starting with the
eigen states corresponding to eigen
value lambda 1 which Arps I 1 1 then Phi
1 2 all the way to PI 1 V 1 then we
start with the eigen States
corresponding to lambda 2 and so on
there are G 1 eigen States corresponding
to eigen value lambda 1 G 2
corresponding to lambda 2 and so on and
the total number of eigen state is n
before moving on remember that we can
make any linear combination between the
stage in G 1 or between the stage in G 2
and so on and the resulting new set of n
linear
independent state with also be item
states of a this last observation about
linear combinations means that we can
make alternative set of eigenstate of a
by rotating those that share the same
eigenvalue this is the key idea behind
gram-schmidt orthonormalization which i
introduced in the video on hermitian
operators it allows us to turn the
initial set of eigenstate of a which are
linearly independent to a new set of
cuts which are also eigenstates of a
width which form an orthonormal basis
moving on I will assume that we have
already done this so that the beside and
I are themselves mutually orthonormal
because now we have a composite index
and I orthonormality tells us this the
rest of the video relies on the matrix
formulation of quantum mechanics we know
that the matrix representing an operator
written in the basis spanned by its own
eigenstate is a diagonal matrix with the
diagonal entries given by the
eigenvalues of the operator that means
that in the PSI n i basis au will be
diagonal matrix in which all off
diagonal terms are 0 and i schematically
represent it like this we want to prove
that if a and B commute then we can find
the common set of eigenstates for a and
B such that when we write a and B in
this common basis both of them are
diagonal to start let's see what the
operator B looks like when written in
the original basis I and I of eigenstate
of a the relevant matrix elements are B
and I n prime i prime which are given by
this expression we usually have a single
index for each basis ket but here we
explicitly keep two because we want to
make sure we treat the Genesis properly
so what does this matrix element look
like let's start with the case through
which n is different from n prime which
corresponds to eigenstate of a with
different eigen values as we have
different eigen values the index I
doesn't really matter in this case so to
simplify notation I will omit it for the
time being we can write sy n a b sy n
prime and we can then use the fact that
sy n is an eigenstate of a with
eigenvalues lambda n to obtain this
expression here if we instead look at sy
n ba si an prime we can again use the
eigenvalue equation for a to get lambda
n prime and then we obtain this because
I am B commute by hypothesis then these
two terms are equal and we can set the
right hand sides also equal to each
other as we're considering the case in
which M is different from n Prime and
this term is not zero so this equality
can only be true if the matrix element
of B vanishes if we recover the eye
index then we can write this final
expression for n different from n prime
what happens when N equals n prime in
this case the term here is zero so you
can no longer conclude that the matrix
element vanishes to make progress let's
write again that the matrix element of B
between bases states correspond to
different eigenvalues vanishes let's
then repeat the list of eigenstates that
we wrote at the very beginning taking
into account the g4 degeneracies of
these states what we want is to build
the matrix representation of B in this
basis and to do that we start with the
top-left square corner it gives a square
portion of the B matrix of sites G 1 and
G 1 corresponding to the representation
of B in terms of the blue base scats
that all share the eigenvalue lambda 1
the matrix element of B in the Blue
Square shared the same end so we cannot
say that they are 0 and the shaded
region signifies that they are in
general not 0 we can then do the same
for the set of green eigenstates which
gives the next block in the diagonal of
sites G 2 spanned by all the eigenstates
corresponding to eigenvalue lambda 2
again we cannot say that the matrix
elements inside the green block vanish
we can repeat this for the orange
eigenstates corresponding to lambda 3
and so on well we can say from the fact
that the matrix element of B vanishes
between eigen state of different n is
that all the matrix elements outside
these colored squares are 0 a matrix
that has this shape is called the block
diagonal matrix and unfortunately it is
telling us that B is not diagonal when
written in the side basis of eigenstate
of a so a.m. B do not share this common
set of eigen States but all is not lost
let's focus on a particular block of the
matrix corresponding to eigen value
lambda N and of dimension GN by GN in
this block the index n is redundant so
we can label the matrix element of B by
the I and I Prime indices only to write
them like this this is the part of the B
opera
in the blog spanned by the a eigenstates
corresponding to lambda n and we can
think of it as its own little GN by G n
square matrix as B is a hermitian
operator then all its matrix elements
are equal to their transpose conjugate
elements and in particularly those in
the GN blog will also bei this relation
this means that the smaller BN matrix is
itself hermitian as such we can build
its eigenvalue equation which we write
like this the eigenstates fine form a
basis in the GN dimensional space in
which this b n matrix lives and as such
we can rewrite this BN matrix in the
basis of its own item states with matrix
elements are shown here giving the BN
matrix as diagonal in this basis so how
is this helping us we can write the Phi
in the side basis of eigen state of the
operator a because those eigenstates
also form a basis in this GN dimensional
subspace let's act with a on the five
states we can then insert the expansion
of Phi in the upside basis as shown here
a is a linear operator so you can move
it inside the sum to get its action on
sy and J the sigh or the original
eigenstate of a and overall we get
lambda n sy and J this means that the
five items states are also eigenstate of
a with eigenvalue lambda this of course
was to be expected the GN dimensional
subspace is spanned by eigenstate of the
a matrix i have the same eigenvalue and
we know from the video noggin values and
eigen states that we can make any linear
combination and obtain another
eigenstate of a with the same eigenvalue
what the Phi R is simply one such linear
combination but this is it
in the file and bases the part of the a
matrix living in this GN dimensional
subspace is still diagonal what this all
means is that although the original
eigen States sigh of a associated with
the degenerate eigen value are not
necessarily eigenstate of B and as we
obtain a block diagonal matrix for B in
the upside basis this here shows that it
is always possible to choose in every
eigen subspace of a a basis of
eigenvectors common to a and B with in
this case is the Phi basis therefore in
these five bases we can write both a and
B are diagonal matrices and we have
original statement if two hermitian
operators a and B commute then we can
always find an orthonormal basis of
state space made of eigenstates common
to a and B now that we have proved what
we set out to prove we can write the
eigenvalue equations for a and B with
the common eigenstates phi NPI in these
eigenstates the label n refers to the
fact that the eigenstate is associated
with eigenvalue lambda n of operator a
the label p refers to the fact that the
eigenstate is associated with eigenvalue
mu p of operator B and the index I like
earlier simply appears to deal with
different eigen states that have the
same eigenvalue with this it actually
becomes trivial to prove the inverse of
the statement that we spend this video
proving if there is a basis of
eigenstates common to am B then a and B
commute to show it let's write a and B
acting on the common basis ket fine
operating with B on Phi gives the eigen
value mu so we can write this and then
operating with a on v gives the
eigenvalue lambda so we end up with this
similarly we can write B a acting on the
common basis Cadfael now we first
operate with AE to get lambda and then
with B to get me subtracting these two
equations gives this for the left-hand
side and the right-hand side vanishes
this gives the commutator of a and B
acting on Phi which equals 0 and finally
as the five heads form a basis we can
write any cat in state space in terms of
these basis cats so this implies that a
MB commute overall if a MB commute then
we can find a common set of eigenstates
that form a basis in the state space and
conversely if two operators a and B have
a common basis of eigenstates then these
operators commute so what have we
learned about compatible observables we
can find a common set of eigenstates for
two operators that commute and that in
turn means that we can simultaneously
diagonalize the matrices associated with
these two operators what we can do now
is to define a complete set of commuting
observables which is something that
allows us to uniquely identify quantum
states so I encourage you to check out
the video on that topic
if
you like the video you'd like to send me
suggestions for future videos please
subscribe